sur patient est venu par mon père qui
était un ancien coureur cycliste dans
les années 1960 et un bon l'année où je
suis né et bon jeu j'ai peaufiné comme
ça j'ai nommé venu jean-claude d'écossé
là j'ai vu que je pouvais faire quelque
chose comme chaque matin depuis dix ans
claude se rend dans son atelier situé
près de paris
cet ancien coureur cycliste né à pointe
à pitre et mécaniciens à l'union
sportive de créteil
claude bien l'accompagner pendant deux
semaines son équipe et de partager avec
elles les moments intenses du 51ème tour
cycliste de guadeloupe
cet avenant souvenir le journal
du tout la relooker et le fascicule
voilà ces nombreux neuf banques ont
appelé moment bien marché tu as ton
petit protégé qui fait que gagner tous
les dimanches à bord unique a day c'est
parce que moi aussi je vois la tête du
vainqueur avec monsieur je connais de
nom n'était au courant prend un autre
hôpital et je connaissais pas de but
voilà c'est camacho qui renonça au long
des voies effectivement sens colombien
qui écoute de ceux qui venaient à 26 ans
camacho a créé la surprise sur près de
1200 km de routes
sa régularité lui a permis d'inscrire
son nom au palmarès des grands
vainqueurs du tour
on n'a pas bien
c'est pas pour le public et son fan du
vélo puisque ils sont tout le temps au
bord de la route avec leur poste dans
nos oreilles
même les pompiers pendant leurs heures
de permanence dans nos camions en train
d'écouter deux tours c'est je comprends
tout à fait que c'est un sport le sport
numéro un quand je vois il ya dix ans
quand guadeloupéen n'a pas gagné le tour
de la guadeloupe le dernier en date ces
jeunes molière qui gagnent ils étaient
de la guadeloupe c'est ça je pense que
le public et attend encore en cours
aucun cas elle ne peut le co2
nous pour eux ils veulent pas travailler
ils veulent pas faire des entraînements
poussés moi je suis sûr que moi quand
j'ai fait des entraînements poussés je
me suis sacrifié pendant 12 ans et
maintenant quand les gens me voient
m'amuser mais je sais que j'ai un nom je
suis molia gêne et tout le monde me
reconnaît et je pense que tout le monde
sache ce que j'ai fait à vélo
bah je n'en pensais pas une victoire où
je sais même pas combien que j'ai
emporté
j'ai fait du tour international j'étais
toujours un leader de rechange
messieurs les coureurs
mesdames messieurs le 51ème tour
cycliste de la guadeloupe
inscrit au calendrier international
démarre ce soir avec cette cérémonie de
présentation des équipes des sponsors à
tout le public
bienvenue aux équipes invitées
cuba venezuela canada grande bretagne
lui un script et la martinique et enfin
notre dernier invité le japon conduit
par un ancien vainqueur du tour de la
guadeloupe
philippe mauduit à toutes ces équipes
nous leur souhaitons bonne chance
1re étape contre-la-montre individuel de
baie mahault 120 coureurs prennent le
départ seuls 65 d'entre eux franchiront
la ligne à petit lourd à l'arrivée de la
neuvième et dernière étape aujourd'hui
l'important n'est pas de gagner et
d'impressionner l'adversaire
demain dans le peloton il s'agira de
faire gagner l'équipe
avant terme
le départ du premier coureur camp
rennais sa rivale aux primaires il
entendait de l'insee minhotos ci dessous
le suspense dure tout au long du couloir
c'est daniel bernard le triple vainqueur
du tour qui s'élance le dernier il
réalise le meilleur temps le maillot
rouge de son équipe
l'union sportive du lamentin et porté
sur les plus hautes marches du podium
loto de la guadeloupe a été créé à
l'occasion du premier centenaire la fête
du centenaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé en 1948 pas précisément
cette équipe de jeunes journalistes de
match de camille jabot camille jabot qui
avait reçu une délégation du président
de la fédération française de l'époque
cashes roinard qui officialise est en
quelque sorte le cyclisme dans
dujon la guadeloupe devenue département
départementaux 946 et qu'ils avaient
pensé donc organiser cette grande
épreuve qui était très simple à faire
il s'agissait de tours de la grande
terre puisque j séparé en deux et le
tour de la guadeloupe proprement dite
début des années soixante dix alors
alain pauline originaire de la grande
terre alain était coureur qu'on avait
découvert dans ce qu'on appelle appelait
à l'époque les courses marron des cons
sauvage organisé aigle et qui ne
rassemble pas les coureurs office
licenciés et lui saturé moulias c'était
un coureur du côté du barreau du
lamentin qui ont tenu la vedette pendant
une bonne dizaine d'années auprès auprès
que la guadeloupe est séparé en deux
parties
alors il y avait ce qui avait conduit 2
ce qui lui manque pour montanier est
loin voulais me battre
alors si je parle pauline vient avec
tout le peloton c'est le peloton la mine
mais moi quand c'est moi politique est
parti personne ne mène pas pour moi
parce qu'on a indiqué je suis trop font
alors moi j'ai fait des courses ce mois
celle contre tout le monde et c'est
pourquoi quand je pars à l'étranger
j'étais toujours classé mieux que et
khâgne à des étrangers ici c'est moi
toujours là pour me voir au psg sur deux
jours ce bon 3e minimum quand je fais
moins des troisièmes tout le monde perd
il ya les gens qui sont venus enrichir
ma je connais les gens je ne dis pas que
sont venus à côté de moi qui me kim à
dire voilà cinquante mille fois parce
que j'ai gagné sur toi il ya des gens
qui m'a donné 500 mille fois hélas les
gens qui lui a fait plus que ça mais je
ne dis pas et je savais même pas
imaginer qu'une mince soit il ya les
gens vidic et j'ai acheté des maisons de
mai
saulzoir sallaumines déblocage blanche
est ok avant le départ de chaque étape
les coureurs parcourent plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres cet échauffement
leur permet de se mettre en jambes avant
l'épreuve du jour
je suis triste d'avoir été une affaire
concernant la masse la moye évoluer pour
être digne sur le plan socio-économique
et on a retrouvé donc des ouvriers
agricoles des coupeurs de cannes qui
monte à vélo des gens qui travaillaient
dans leurs champs des paysans et
maintenant petit à petit on sent qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de deux jeunes lycéens
qui viennent au vélo et le jeune
étudiant même qui viennent au vélo c'est
un train de prendre de plus en plus
à quoi t'attendre rolla bolla bongo la
sécurité qu'il se battait au japonais
qui après avoir gagné là aujourd'hui
dans les champs de canne suffisamment de
temps pour s'entraîner effet nous avons
vu le dimanche en pousse à cette époque
là aussi c'est tout gestion coureur de
chez nous pouvait lire deux mots un
franc serait maintenant deschamps les
temps ont changé
le pouvoir ou une autre dimension
sociale d'ailleurs tous passent par les
malades écoles y en a pas mal qui sont
bacheliers qui s'exprime d'une manière
extraordinaire mieux que moi et puis ce
sont les gens qui n'ont plus faim si je
dois m'exprimer ainsi
c'est qu'on croit il
il ya quelques années vivent dans le
cyclisme nous devions nous avons pu
souffrir
efforçons nous n'avons pris fin
on n'est pas toujours habitué à faire
des efforts sur le plan intellectuel des
lots compatit clos on croit qu'il suffit
d'être bon dans les gens d'avoir de
bonnes jambes et que bon et
fonctionnaires restent sains alors nous
on nous nous battons pour que les
coureurs accède non seulement à un
niveau de production dans un travail à
l'entraînement mais également une élève
le niveau de l'eau culture cycliste
à 9 heures précises on donne le départ
devant la mairie dhabi mme comme chaque
année depuis la création du tour un
public de plus en plus nombreux à
répondre aux appels de la caravane
tonitruante dès l'aube n'est plus
passionnés recherchent les meilleurs
emplacements au bord de la route
ce sont des matins c'est vrai que c'est
pas vraiment bien payé contrairement au
regard de l'évolution de ce sport bondi
bec on n'aurait plus vraiment donner
davantage de sault cyclisme ici vraiment
au niveau de la région l'état vraiment
les aider davantage parce que quand on
regarde la modique somme qu'ils
perçoivent en fin de tour c'est pas
évident après autant d'efforts c'est pas
le cyclisme doit être d'aider en
guadeloupe absolument
allez
jeune fan de vélo déjà et j'aime le vélo
est le sport national de la guadeloupe
voilà je me déplace chaque année tout le
temps avec ma famille comme ça c'est
elle c'est ma copine c'est ma famille à
mon frère et la belle-soeur ici et on
est là à chaque année comme ça toutes
les étapes jusqu'à la fin au cours de
leur carrière les coureurs ont rarement
l'occasion de voir un public aussi
chaleureux que celui des routes du tour
de la guadeloupe
ici plus qu'ailleurs la bicyclette
mérite bien son surnom de petite reine
c'est un doigt
je
sur un tour cycliste chaque minute
compte
après l'arrivée de l'étape les coureurs
des jeunes ensembles parti se reposer
enfreint vient l'heure du massage
pendant ce temps les mécaniciens soigne
les machines est un ancien conseiller
on se connaît les coureurs je sais bien
qu'il aime bien avant les vélos équipés
à l'hôtel voilà c'est encore du temps
s'il ya pas de mécano il n'y a pas
d'équipé le mécano il est primordial
dans l'équipe en plus du directeur
sportif ou matin il faut qu'ils soient
des lycéens étrangers
si vous passez votre nation nation de
loi qui a pas de graisses saturées
voilà le fait que commencer
impossible dès lors la vitesse passe et
de l'huile et c'est reparti pour des
moteurs moi je parraine le look de la
gimone toit sans donner de grosses
gouttes
je suis à dix stations comme cette année
depuis l'âge de 13 ans c'est un sport
qui est difficile mais quand même sa
difficulté emmène un charme que qui fait
que pendant le tour de tous afin que
tout le monde
nous la plupart des gars qui font du
vélo ce sont des salariés
alors on ne peut pas dire qu'un bon
surtout gagner des sous certes quand on
gagne des sous mais il faudrait pas
vouloir gagner sa vie avec ma vie noir
onemi je vais pas gagner la vis à vis à
minuit c'est en guadeloupe c'est un
sport l'après pouces atteint beaucoup
plus aux loisirs ont fait du fait du
cycle droit d'option
c'est comme l'a finie et c'est sûr de
travail on va savoir l'entraînement
n'est pas public sur dix salariés pour
faire du vélo parcours j'ai du parcours
le sommeil dit zhang
après ça va être tout en vélo n'est
d'emprise de remonter un bazar et
apprend attack s'impose alors vous
prenez pas non plus la tête avec qui
sont autant un l'étape de montagne
simplement
le sérieux et les points comme on
rentrait pas non plus non mais faut
relativiser les mamelles paul alpe
d'huez à monk longtemps certes mais les
mecs qui marche commentée en plateau la
barre ces facteurs faisceau de la
guadeloupe donc et une partie des
parties du de mes congés annuels que je
prends pour venir ici pour j'ai fait le
tour de la martinique déjà en une
quinzaine d'années on voit donc j'étais
pas venu mais je pense que
ça se ressemble un petit peu au niveau
de la course un petit peu en quoi un
psycho et que les mêmes coureurs laisser
d'amérique et enfin toujours
intéressante enregistrent de l'avis des
coureurs
les nuits sont trop courtes la chaleur
et l'accumulation de la fatigue excite
les organismes il est parfois difficile
de trouver le sommeil
la journée des coureurs commencent tôt à
5h30
tout le monde est debout trois heures
avant le départ il faut manger et
accueillir et une réserve de moins 3000
calories avant le premier habituellement
de la course à la montée
on l'a raté et après on alors descendre
sur le quai de khat est deuxième et on
finit par tout quand on sait que
j'aurais cru qu'on
star nationale pemex c'est vraiment
impressionnant dans leurs montagnes pour
ça tant que firent les écarts au
magistrat d'en face le parfum black 200
morts il devait par sa part tous les
jours qu'un pétrole
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il a une
pareille notamment
là vous avez vu tout le
la première partie avant d'attaquer les
mamelles on prend toute la route que
vous avez pris hier débat la nationale
la petite route on va la prendre ainsi
que la nationale donc ça va être même
topographie ça va être comme ça
et les mecs pour mettre en route
d'entrée de balle mais pas les mêmes que
d'habitude ça va être les gosses les
grimpeurs c'est plus bord de mer 1
ça promet
des rapports
je vais
toujours en pensant qu'elle ingère point
qu avant ils préfèrent souvent par de
sombres
mais
ils n'ont pas l'habitude des colts
aujourd'hui l'étape est cruciale
capesterre 5 le 115 km
trois cols de première catégorie dont
les mamelles affranchis et au final les
six kilomètres de côtes de saint claude
pour atteindre l'arrivée depuis le
départ du tour on compte une vingtaine
d' abandon au cours de cette étape de
montagne
la liste va se rallonger d'une quinzaine
de noms les organismes sont mis à rude
épreuve et l'énergie abandonnent les
coureurs les plus fragiles non finale
le groupe a jugé qu est derrière qui est
pas très loin tu montes à ta main ça se
trouve vite retombé sur le point
tu vois tes pas loin c'est pas loin
c'est tout bon
aux difficultés du relief il faut
ajouter la résistance du vent ainsi que
la chaleur de l'air à mesure que la
course avance l'effort et la douleur
marque les visages certains coureurs
lune jusqu'à épuisement de leurs forces
et finissent par abandonner
d'autres résistent jusqu'à la ligne
d'arrivée puis ces fours ils sont
nombreux sur la chaume français à faire
le tour de la guadeloupe à ce cas il
faut savoir depuis soixante dix
nous invitons ou une ou deux équipes
françaises ou deux où une équipe de
comité régional français régulièrement
chaque année 1 cette année c'est l'us
créteil et là nous souhaitons que la
réciproque soit vraie et que nous
sollicitons des échanges nous avons
discuté avec l us créteil
nous ne sommes pas obligés d'avoir une
échange au niveau des élites mais au
niveau de nos gènes des cadets des
juniors que nous voudrions faire voyager
courir en france pour qu'ils voient
comment se passent les courses en france
comment le peloton de leur catégorie
roule en france pour qu'il revienne avec
d'autres dispositions
un peloton de retardataires continue de
s'accrocher mais les derniers arrivent à
saint-claude avec plus d'une heure de
retard et sont disqualifiés leur courage
aura été vain sida les coureurs auront
tout donné
c'est cet héroïsme que le public acclame
passage de la ligne dames
du canada tel aviv avait les mêmes
atouts de la guadeloupe où le col des
mamans n'est pas franchie pas au maillot
pointe noire et compagnie c'est pas
chaque fois que le tour a été dessiné
avec ces difficultés il ya toujours
trois ou quatre guadeloupéen a les dix
premiers du classement général
aujourd'hui on en avant aucun donc par
conséquent l'autre il faut déceler si le
tout avec ses difficultés
ça m'arrive de ne pouvoir rehausser son
écrin l'a1 est ajouté à sa voix nomi à
la limite tu peux retenir un petit peu
les pédales toi tu peut les retenir
ah oui tu as tes gants est ce que tu
fais c'est qu'il sert de ta main tu te
sers tu vois ce que tu peux faire pour
qui son retard et et c'est que tu mets
ta main pour le cnoa la vente doit
freiner répondant en compte le grand ça
sert aussi à ça
l'équipe de créteil et rentrait de
guadeloupe la tête pleine de souvenirs
et les jambes encore endolori les jeunes
coureurs ont repris l'entraînement
dans quelques semaines qui doivent être
rejoints par de jeunes espoirs
guadeloupéens dans le cadre d'un échange
inter club claude toujours prêt à
transmettre son expérience et sa passion
à la nouvelle génération
les encadreurs
salute la boîte d'assad
au delà
à
or là bang aulas or la banderole a
beaucoup la bombe
madame à sanaa où vous les lois toute la
vague et la vie